[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir ein
hauptgericht und zwar ein typisch
marokkanisches wir machen was sie ja was
dir halt das habe ich zum allerersten
mal bei ungefähr zwei jahren auf eine
marokkanische noch zeitig essen und ich
dachte nur super was habe ich all die
jahre verpasst so lecker das ist ihr
müsst euch das vorstellen das ist ein
fehlurteil und das ist gefüllt mit
lecker hähnchen einer nuss mischung und
seine abschiebelager passiert ist kann
ich gar nicht beschreiben ich zeig euch
jetzt schritt für schritt und dann hoffe
ich natürlich dass sie das auch fleißig
nachmacht
wir benötigen hähnchen ich habe hier
hähnchenbrustfilet genommen
außerdem wasser hier habe ich schon
zwiebeln ganz fein gehackt neutrales
evtl
petersilie und koriander ebenfalls fein
gehackt außerdem eier und an gewürzen
benötigen wir salz pfeffer zimt gemeinen
ingwer kurkuma und safran rom ein
kochtopf steht bereit ich gebe zu
allererstes öl hinein die zwiebeln und
dann günstig das gemeinsam mit peter
seele koriander und den gewürzen schön
an
[Musik]
den ingwer habe ich immer gemahlen zu
hause ihr könnt natürlich auch frische
nehmen und den dann einfach klein
stellen ist auch kein problem zum satz
war wollte ich euch noch sagen also das
schmeckt super lecker wenn ihn mit
reingeht ich weiß aber dass er schwer zu
kriegen ist das hat ist es auch nicht so
schön wenn ihr du nicht mit rein gibt
aber ich gebe den gerne noch in die
handinnenflächen und macht ihr noch mal
so ein bisschen klein und dann gebe ich
ihm erst in den topf
jetzt riecht alles gut umgeschaltet den
herd ein und das ganze schön auf
mittlerer stufe circa fünf minuten lang
dünsten lassen
[Musik]
nach fünf minuten sieht die massen so
aus also alles schön weich geworden und
ihr müsst einfach mal dran riechen
das riecht einfach so richtig ich stelle
mir das so vor wenn ich durch marokko
dickmacher cash.life berichts auf den
straßen genauso ich weiß doch niemand ob
wir vergeben wir jetzt unser händchen
rein einige nehmen auch ein richtiger
hähnchenkeule mit mit knochen aber ich
mache das jetzt so ich finde es so
einfach irgendwie ein bisschen einfacher
später auch wenn zur weiterverarbeitung
gibt es komplett rein so also die
richtlinie ist ungefähr ein kilo fleisch
aber bei mir sind jetzt 13 kilo ihr
könnt auch 900 gramm also wetter nicht
so streng
es gab trotzdem
[Musik]
die hähnchenbrustfilets dürfen jetzt
fünf minuten ungefähr mit braten und
jetzt löschen wir das ganze mit wasser
ab und zwar so viel biss die
hähnchenbrustfilets gerade so bedeckt
sind
so jetzt das ganze einmal aufkochen
lassen dann schalten wir das ganze
runter damit es ungefähr 40 bis 45
minuten köcheln kann
und da gibt ja am besten den deckel
drauf
während das jetzt mit geschlossenem
deckel vor sich hin köcheln machen wir
weiter mit der nuss füllung denn neben
dieser hähnchen füllung gibt es noch
eine art nuss füllung und da gibt es
verschiedene varianten entweder nimmt
dem handel
aber die müsst ihr noch heute das heißt
ich gebe euch hier den tipp können das
mit heißem wasser übergießen fünf
minuten warten und dann heute die sich
quasi von alleine da müsste schon ein
bisschen nachhelfen
ich mache es mir jetzt anders ein
bisschen einfacher ich nehme hier diese
gestifteten mandeln die sind ja quasi
schon gehäutet und weiß so lecker findet
nämlich noch cashewkerne mit rein und
die müssen wir zuallererst anrösten in
einer freien beschichteten pfanne macht
die stufe eures herd ist nicht so hoch
weil sonst brennt euch an und das wäre
total schade und ich mache das jetzt
auch in zwei schritten weil er mir
verschiedene größen brauchen
unterschiedlich lang ich nehme jetzt
erstmal die gestifteten mandl gibt die
hier rein und du hast dich die an und
dann mache ich mit den cashewkerne
weiter
[Musik]
die mandeln sind jetzt richtig schön
gold brauchen jetzt geht es hier in
meinen blender so man kann natürlich
auch ganz lassen die sind ja so schon
klein arbeiten macht das lieber wenn man
die noch mal ein bisschen mix als
nächstes sind die cashewkerne dran die
werden jetzt auch noch richtig schön
gerüstet und dann geht es weiter
für die gerüsteten caches und die
mandeln habe ich jetzt so ein bisschen
scheint also ich sag mal da sind noch
stücke drehen ich mag das so lieber ihr
könnt sie auch fein mixen ist auch kein
problem ich zeig euch mal meine variante
also man sieht da ist auf jeden fall
noch bis drin
und jetzt gebe ich die riesige schüssel
so und jetzt kommt's zwei weitere
zutaten hinzu nämlich puderzucker und
jetzt dinge so wurde herzhaften essen
vertraut mir und vertraut der
marokkanischen küche das passt so gut
gehen wie puderzucker hinzu um die
zweite wichtige zutat ist und so orange
blüten wasser und jetzt wird das ganze
richtig gut miteinander verrührt die
nuss mischung das jetzt gut verrührt die
brauchen wir später erst wieder also
gebe ich das an die seite mal schauen
was in unserem top los ist eine halbe
stunde ist rum
ich gebe dem ganzen noch 15 minuten und
dann geht's weiter
die kochzeit ist jetzt umgezogenen
zuallererst unser hähnchen raus und
lassen es aber gut abtrocknen
bevor wir uns gleich die finger
verbrennen können die ganz kurz
ausdampfen erinnert euch noch an die
eier die ich euch zu beginn gezeigt habe
ich habe hier sieben kleinere könnte
auch sechs große dem ist gar kein
problem und die runden wir jetzt nach
und nach in diese ziegel so seien also
immer nach und nach und nicht alles auf
einmal
[Musik]
die zwiebel eimasse ist jetzt am kochen
und das ganze dauert auch so um die zehn
minuten ist kommt natürlich immer darauf
an wie viel wasser er dazu gegeben habt
denn das wasser muss jetzt komplett
verdampfen alternativ könnt ihr das auch
so abschöpfen aber die elegantere
variante ist einfach dass hier warte bis
das wasser verdampft und dann ist diese
füllung auch fertig wir zehn minuten
sind jetzt um und die ganze flüssigkeit
ist verdampft ich zeige euch mal wieder
dass in ungefähr aussehen sollte also
soll so eine richtig schöne dicke masse
sein
ich will das jetzt kurzum eine schüssel
und dann gehts mit dem hähnchen weiter
die hähnchenbrust filets werden jetzt
auseinander gerückt wenn euch das zu
heiß ist nehmt euch einfach zwei gabeln
und ruft die so auseinander
aber das ganze dürfte jetzt schon 10 12
minuten stehen und es ist nicht mehr
ganz so heißt und jetzt einfach mit den
händen schön auseinander rufen
[Musik]
so dass sitzt vorbereitet ihr braucht
hier nicht zusätzlich salzen denn wir
haben hier in unserer zwiebel einmal die
ganzen gewürze drin und deswegen braucht
ihr das nicht sollten falls ihr das
gefühl habt ihr müsst es tun dann gibt
da wirklich nur so ein kleines bisschen
rein gerne auch ein bisschen zimt aber
ich mache jetzt nicht weil ich halte das
wirklich nicht für nötig und die jetzt
schichten wir das ganze ich mache mir
ganz kurz die hände sauber und dann
zeige ich euch unsere allerletzte zutat
so im leben da bin ich wieder jetzt
bekommt die letzte beziehungsweise die
vorletzte zutat und zwar sind dass diese
viele blätter die habe ich mir so ein
stück ab gemacht die sind so dünn da
kann man sogar durchgucken und das ist
jetzt beim türken war das jetzt der ba
klarer teig hört sich jetzt komisch an
so herres hat butler weiß mit dass die
art zu tun aber er nimmt auf jeden fall
diesen bagdad icon das ist der richtige
philo teig und dann brauchen wir
natürlich noch geschmolzene butter und
jetzt werde ich zuallererst mit der
geschmolzene butter meine form
bestreichen
jetzt beginnen wir mit dem boden und
dafür müssen wir zuallererst unsere
viele blätter nehmen und den boden aus
legen was ihr dabei beachten ist es
folgendes ergibt das solar drauf und
lasst es aber zur hälfte raus hängen so
entgeht der einmal reihum bist du das
ganze voll habt
diese viele blätter sind übrigens
eigentlich doppelt so groß ich habe mir
jetzt in der hälfte einmal
durchgeschnitten weil so kann man
einfach viel besser arbeiten vergisst
nicht immer wieder mit der butter auf
die viele blätter zu gehen denn sonst
wären sie ist total knusprig und wir
wollen die ja eher ein bisschen weicher
haben
[Musik]
so legt am besten zwei bis drei
schichten vom philo tag darauf denn wenn
ihr nur 1 geschichte hat dann ist das
ganze so ein bisschen unstabil
[Musik]
so dass ein grundgerüst ist schon mal
fertig die bastia oder basteln
mich würde interessieren wie er das
ausspricht schreibt sie noch gerne und
in die kommentare
jedenfalls wir das jetzt befüllt
zuallererst mit der hand in hübschen
hähnchen schicht und das geht jetzt
einfach komplett hier drauf
und jetzt drücke ich das ganze ein wenig
an einfach mit den händen so
[Musik]
so nun haben jetzt zwei möglichkeiten
entweder gibt ihr das komplett auf das
häkchen oder er gibt da noch eine
schicht vom philo tag darauf das mache
ich jetzt sowie gesetze zu euch
überlassen
ihr könnt auch direkt drauf machen
nun kommt die zwiebel masse darüber die
geben wir einfach komplett drauf
[Musik]
so jetzt empfehle ich euch definitiv
kilo teig auf die schicht zu geben denn
als nächstes kommen ja unsere nüsse und
dann ist einfach leckere wenn er so eine
schicht von kilo teig dazwischen ist und
vergiss nicht immer schön mit der butter
bestreichen
er wird die viel besser drauf habe
ungefähr drei lagen gemacht und jetzt
kommt die leckeren muss schicht darüber
das einzige was wir jetzt noch machen
müssen ist das ganze schließen mit den
blättern die wir hier außen herum haben
und wir haben ja noch ein paar übrig das
heißt wir können auch den abschluss noch
mal richtig schön machen damit es auch
optisch gut aussieht
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann mit eurer form soweit
zufrieden seid gibt ihr das in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze so ihr lieben die bastler
ist jetzt fertig die hat ganz genau 20
minuten gebraucht bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze im ofen und ich bin gespannt
wie sie haben sie schmecken wird ich
weiß dass es super lecker ist haben sagt
sie nicht von mir noch nicht probiert
und gleichzeitig natürlich nach dem amt
den anschnitt und ich wollte euch noch
ganz kurz was zur deko sagen es ist ganz
typisch dass man da auch puderzucker
drauf macht und singt klingt
ungewöhnlich ich weiß aber probiert es
gerne mal aus
[Musik]
was die jaaa ist ein bisschen
zeitaufwendig es stimmt aber es ist
super lecker und ich finde der aufwand
lohnt sich total vor allem kriegt man
damit auch viele menschen so etwas ja
auch super cool ist falls das ganze
jetzt noch machen möchte dann schaut
gern mal unten in die infobox da habe
ich für euch alle genauen mengenangaben
aufgeschrieben ich freue mich über fotos
auf instagram mit dem hashtag s kitchen
und ansonsten wünsche ich euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen guten appetit und
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
mit ganzen war auch immer gewicht
umzutauschen mir ja die passt noch nicht
kennen
ihr müsst das noch machen so schön ist
so lecker das schmeckt so lecker so an
tag 2 wir essen immer noch bastian und
hier ist der kuchen dem heute gefeiert
haben und selbst fraglich die immer so
landwehr ist okay besser ehrlich
[Musik]